hey guys I'm your joy Graceffa lova yay
Joey is here and we recorded an episode
of not too deep and it was really really
fun I learned so much about the origin
of your dog
it doesn't really it was delightful but
now Joey has agreed to stick around and
shoot the speech jammer challenge with
me this afternoon for all of you that
don't know speech jammer is an app that
you can download on your phone for free
and it basically delays your own voice
while you're talking in real time so it
makes it very difficult to finish
sentences to sing songs etc so we are
going to go back and forth each trying
to recite things that we have memorized
like the alphabet and the Pledge of
Allegiance and we're going to see who
can get further along in each song or
diddy I'm so excited to get if this is
actually as heard as making it out I
mean it's it's just it's so seemingly
simple that it's frustrating that you
can't get through things haha and then
we're gonna keep score and see who can
get through the most amount of these
universally memorized songs and and such
are you ready yeah okay we're gonna
start seemingly really simple with the
alphabet all right would you like to go
first or second I'll go first you go
first
okay we'll see how far in the alphabet
you can get okay
ABCD efg hijk little peak here
all right you guys like blue you got the
cute oh my god
it's very intense you might have just
had a stroke I think that's what
happened I was like oh my god this is so
easier than my mouth was just saying
thing oh my god like the devil okay you
have much farther than I thought you
would get here we go
ABCD efg hijk LMNOP QRS
you beat me I basically goes oh okay
okay maybe I got take this off that was
a tie oh maybe a warm-up so um the next
is the Pledge of Allegiance okay do you
think you can thinks I think I remember
it oh my god I'm probably gonna mess up
anyways it's okay all right I pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
is your government enough oh my god why
does it do that
why does it do that why I'm in a cell
like you are so good is it one nation
under God into Congress that happen I
don't know he's so bizarre honestly that
was really impressive and it was like
he's on track he's doing it and then oh
no I enjoy the Pledge of Allegiance
oh okay focus grace here we go
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under way I think we kept like the same
spotter yeah okay you got one nation
under God ha ha ha so it's
very stressful because you're like I got
this I got this just right it's on your
mouth just focus out and then I like
takes over and like you have no control
then next is twinkle twinkle little star
I think I remember this one okay I have
faith in you here we go twinkle twinkle
star twinkle twinkle little star how I
wonder what you are like a diamond in
the sky up above the world so high
twinkle to know closer what I don't know
what we're saying oh no I mean I still I
was very impressed with that thank you
twinkle twinkle little star how I wonder
what you are up above the world so high
like a diamond in the sky twinkle
twinkle little star how I wonder whether
what you up hahahaha what happens when
you start going fast with no like
delight like with no brakes in your own
speech that's when maybe we should do
that that's the new rule yes you can
okay yeah oh all right uh what was the
last one that we had said the itsy-bitsy
spider went up the water spout down came
the rain and washed the spider out I
just should say it's so fast yeah you
have to go as fast as you can okay Motor
Speedway the itsy bitsy spider went up
the water spout down came the rain and
washed the spider out out came the Sun
and dried up all the rain two
instruments [ __ ]
whoa I can't wait to watch the style you
are nothing if not putting in a hundred
and fifty percent effort we did
appreciate thank you okay I'm gonna try
and go as fast as possible and go
through it the itsy bitsy spider one of
the rafts was fun brain I was spy out
defecate the Sun pad above the rain and
there's mrs. Desmond yeah oh my god I
feel like I couldn't do an impression of
someone having a stroke that's right
there was no creasing this is bringing
it out of my guys you know it it sounds
like when you're listening to it it
sounds like it's like Auto tuning your
voice but that's just how you're talking
yes yes yes yes it literally sounds like
someone is warping your voice as you're
talking yeah because you were saying
twinkle twinkle yeah and it felt like
someone's just turning a toggle and like
changing the hospital star so because
we've been tied this whole time we are
doing a sudden death meaning each of us
will sing a song that we know really
really well and we'll see who can get
through the majority of the song okay
okay my song choice is I like big butts
Oh goodbye okay thank you it's a cult
classic I like big butts and I cannot
lie you other brothers can't deny when a
girl walks I move it is round thing in
your face you get sprung up put up tough
what stop oh my god was it good I got
thrown 11 seconds of it a very generous
eleven seconds okay do you have a song
that you would like to sing don't wait
by Joey Graceffa I don't because Apurva
but it's really good I feel like a
dollar a yeah okay okay I'm gonna start
with the chorus
ah you can do 12 second 12 seconds here
we go we don't wait for the world to be
rare addict or don't can wait
oh my god
I was psyching myself oh oh I like that
remix very good I think we should make a
music video for them oh wow well you
know even though technically I won I
don't feel like I wanna come which you
know that's usually how these challenges
go so we did it Joey thank you for being
here make sure you guys go check out
Joey go check on don't wait go check out
the book that's out and by the time this
comes out you'll have gone through your
tour and all of that but the pros will
be out there okay Joey also make sure
you go over to SoundCloud and iTunes and
listen to the full podcast that we did
there was a lot of really interesting
answers for sure other than that
I'm gonna go trend like regain my sanity
I know I don't know if you could
describe grace in three words what would
those words be mmm three words three
words oh my god okay beautiful confident
and funny wow that's really great I feel
I think my favorites are it's all a lie